are you still beefing with chris evans
yeah
i can't believe he would leak my big my
big big meat like that
yeah that's [ __ ] up so i like i
couldn't i was gonna text you about it
but i was just so upset that i just had
to keep it to myself i just
i understand that you're pissed man like
just to have your
meat out there for everyone to see i
know it's kind of like a invasion of
your privacy
yeah and and and like you know i like i
told you i just
i send it to him in private and what
does he do he leaks it now he takes the
credit for it and now he's telling
everyone to vote
and everyone's voting not realizing that
the whole reason that they're voting is
because it's my gigantic big meet
that they saw right why did you send it
to him though
um i was just afraid like it was just
getting so massive and i was like
oh it's just to get his opinion yeah i
was like is this like is this like a
growth like should i be worried
like because you you got to assume
captain america has a pretty big hog
so i guess that makes sense to to yeah
you'd send it to him like just kind of
knowing listen as someone
with a big dick who i'm assuming you
have a big dick what do you think of my
giant ginormous swollen exactly uh
pulsating member
yeah okay yeah you know i was like you
know i'm
i'm big enough for three charcuterie
boards and it just keeps growing and i
just don't know what to do with myself
right yeah and so what did he say well i
mean he just leaked the picture yeah he
that's the cold part he didn't respond
and then
three days later oh oops
oh oh what are you gonna oh oops my meat
i i'm pretty sure i'm i'm pretty sure i
saw the picture
was it did you see it um
i didn't see so i did but like i saw one
picture that was like black and white
and
super grainy and like weird was that the
one
so uh i just thought like
uh someone sent me the video and i
didn't get it
i was like they just they're just like
lol look at this and i
it was like a it was a screen video yeah
so it was a screen recording
of his friend like doing some like
goofy like iphone game like holding up
to his head or some [ __ ] like that okay
or no it might have been like a a filter
or there's like something
i don't know it was like some game show
looking [ __ ]
and the some dude is in his kitchen and
they're like laughing about it and then
so it's a screen recording of that video
and the video
ends and it minimizes and it's like his
whole photo roll
and so that that ended and then the
[ __ ] and then the
end of the screen recording happened and
i was like i don't get it
and they're like dude look at the photos
and i'm like
oh there's like uh there's a one who was
just like what does that say like guard
your [ __ ]
that's crazy and then oh there's oh damn
that's a dude's dick right there cool
that's my dick that's my dad wait a
minute that's my dick
wait a second so then i called the
police and i was like i have just found
my penis on the internet
and i did not consent to this
hello 9-1-1 i see my dick
what i see my dick i see it i see it
it's in the screen
it's on the screen it's in the screen
it's in the computer how did my how did
my penis get in the computer
sir just eject your disk drive no you
don't get it
it's in there in the computer my penis
is stuck in the computer i need to get
it out
he's stuck in there
yeah i was in i was enraged i
immediately reported the post i dm'd him
i said you take my meat down right now
wow wait what what what did you just say
who i didn't say that
who said what take my meat down right
now i didn't say that
take my meat down right now i didn't say
that at all
who was that captain america please take
my meat
down down right now down take it down
now
bro [ __ ]
what uh just the ultimate humble brag
oh man i just you know i post a little
video and then my [ __ ]
my meat is everywhere what am i gonna do
oh man that's what i'm saying we gotta
start calling them captain underpants
yeah yeah you know yeah
because buddy buddy
buddy should not be ashamed you know
way to go dude way to go chris i don't
know if it's the right picture that i
saw
but it does make sense that it was
grainy and pixelated you know
someone would have blown it up from the
camera roll and that's what i saw
dude independent of that what a [ __ ]
terrifying experience
for him oh yeah i mean just like oh oh
[ __ ] yeah oh [ __ ] i'm captain america
i feel like i feel that feeling that he
had
when you press post and it's like the
video processing and then it goes and he
sees the last frame and it's already up
there
it's just it's sinking it's horrible
like it's too late
what have i done what have i done though
now everyone's going to see my big pee
pee i picked
peepee then he's like hovering his
finger over the delete button he's like
maybe i'll give it a second
i'll give him five seconds his pr person
is like take that down immediately he's
like
he's like should i
let's talk about pros and cons real
quick
if i take it down now then only
10 000 people have seen it but if i wait
just another minute then it could be
twenty five thousand
yeah yeah let's let it simmer let's let
it simmer a little bit why don't we
i just feel like the place like let it
marinate for just a second and then i'll
take it down
i'll be so mad if there's some marketing
agency that's like yeah so we came up
with the idea for jimmy kimmel to create
the fake fire video and we came up with
the idea for the
um chris evans penis vote campaign that
penis is actually not real is generated
using can
um we ingested about 250 000 images of
pornographic
uh frames to create this fake chris
evans penis
yes exactly the penis doesn't actually
exist in real life
chris evans penis is actually quite
average
in size it's just regular um it's just
regular it's a regular dick
it's no captain america's dick as far as
i'm concerned
uh that's my opinion though anyways ai
so yeah this penis was entirely based
or created with ai and um yeah there's
an instagram page for it now
and uh all bulged pictures completely
created with ai and the balls will be
incorporated in the new fall guys season
um all the fall guys will feature
a chris evans inspired bulge
[Laughter]
yeah yeah man bro why is that guy i mean
if that was me why even act why do
anything
yeah we just live just live man
yeah it's just you know it's like a it's
like by the way i i
read like a patreon comment or something
like that from someone that was like
dude the end of the last episode was
pretty
intel oh which way you guys were like
[ __ ] hot people man oh yeah i mean they
get everything
for free blah blah blah yeah that was in
cell whatever
it was intel talk but i but i was just
about to do it again is what i'm saying
it's so long chris evans dude what you
can't it's not enough to be [ __ ]
captain america you got to have a big
ass dick too
yeah it's not enough to be the [ __ ]
top of hollywood bro you gotta have a
[ __ ] hanger too come on man
bro we're not wishing death on anybody
okay and
we're not saying that the world is
doomed all we're saying
is that we have envy okay that's it's
not in cell to have envy
exactly and all we're saying is give us
a little dick yeah not like
what no i'm just saying get chop us off
some dick
you want some dragon you want some
dragon these nuts
nice man you could have got me without
no no no
yeah yeah slice off just slice it you
don't need it all
yeah just slice you don't need all the
dicks
yeah [ __ ] are like tall
rationed it out with the [ __ ] yeah
with the [ __ ] baguette it's like bruh
i don't even i don't that's the thing i
don't even i'm not even
requesting that much more it's just it
could always be better
it's like well if i just had a little if
i just had a little
just a little bit a little vain like get
out like chop off a vein
toss it my way give me just a slick vein
real quick
that's going to be that's that's going
to be the new [ __ ] [ __ ] penis
enlargement it's going to be penis like
um just you know like mr potato head
like you're just picking
yeah yeah yeah it's going to it's going
to be like enhancing it you know what i
mean like
like i want i want my you know i want my
uh
i just want a little a little more vein
in the shaft just like a little just a
little more pump
yeah that's what they need they need
pre-workout but for penises
yeah but it's not viagra it doesn't make
you hard it's just like
you know it just it just makes it makes
your dick really um
jittery and shaky yeah it's got a lot of
caffeine in it
yeah and you have to poop yeah yeah